Hi, everyone.
I'm Gagandeep Singh and I'm
joined by my colleague Xu
Fei. We are Solutions
Engineers at RStudio,
soon to be called Posit.
And we are here to
answer the question
that we get asked a
lot, which is can you
use Python with RStudio Team?
And the answer is, of
course, yes you can.
Very recently I had to
answer this question,
so I'm going to start by
sharing a story with you.
I'm an Indian National.
In order to be here in the
US to attend this conference,
I needed to get a visa.
And as part of the
immigration process,
I have to get an
interview with an officer
where they ask you questions
like, where are you going?
What will you be doing?
So I told them that I'm
going to this conference.
I'm giving a talk about
using Python with RStudio.
The officer said,
oh, I know Python,
but I didn't know you could
use it with RStudio.
I told him that's exactly
what my talk is about.
Unfortunately, Officer
Johnson could not
be here with us today.
But if you are in
the audience, we
are assuming that you
are a multi either
you are a multilingual data
scientist who has access
to RStudio's pro products.
And wants to use
Python with them
or you are an R user
who works with a lot
of Python colleagues,
and you may or may not
have access to our products,
but you're looking for ways
to collaborate with them.
So it is one thing
to say that you can
use Python in RStudio products.
We're here to show you how
to work with the use case.
We're in the DC area
right now and there
is an active bikeshare
program outside called Capital
Bikeshare.
We went out and took
a picture yesterday
and this is the station
right outside of the hotel.
As you can see that
there are bikes
docked into the bike station.
And when you go to
the company's website,
you will see a map that shows
you all the bike stations.
When you click on one
of those stations,
you will show you how many
bikes are available right now
from a live data feed.
Now, what it doesn't
tell you is how many
bikes are going to be
available in the future.
As we know, the
bike availability
varies a lot by the time
of day, the location.
And if we want to have a
smooth trip experience,
we want to be able to predict
how many bikes in the future.
So because there is
a live data feed,
we can actually grab the
data, store it somewhere
and make a predictive model.
So that we can actually know
how many bikes are going
to be available in the future.
So that's we want to do.
If you were here at the
conference back in 2020,
you probably have seen a talk
that uses the similar data set,
that does everything in R packages.
It's actually from
our colleague Alex.
And so this project has
been successfully running
for over two years.
So a lot of data has
been processed and stored
as interoperable data assets
that we'll get back to
in a second.
There's a lot of data
being stored and processed.
When I joined the
company last year
from more of a
Python data science
background and Gagan
and I started talking.
So since we have all these data,
can we do something different?
Can we do something
entirely in Python and using
our pro products?
And we wanted to do
this for two reasons.
Number one, well,
just because we can.
Why not?
Well, that's not
really a good reason.
The second reason is
actually we thought
this could be a very
common scenario where
in our pro product customers,
the teams that are working one
language may want to
collaborate with another team
in a different language
using interoperable data
assets that's completely
deployed in the pro product
ecosystem.
So we are also thinking that
the conference is in DC,
so we actually get to go
to DC and write those bikes
and here we are.
So let's recap the workflow for
the bike prediction use case.
As in with any other project,
it starts with the data
source, which in this case
is the Capital Bike
Share API and the data
is refreshed every day.
Then the objective is
to import this data,
transform it, and save
it either in the database
or an interoperable
data asset like pins.
So based on the
frequency of the update,
then we have to
consume this data,
build our prediction
model to show
the number of bikes
for each bike station.
Then we have to move this
model to a deployable location
where the output, the
predictions of number of bikes
can be shared with
other applications.
And speaking of
other applications,
we have to build a way to share
the predictions with our users.
As in the previous
talk, this work is already
available and running
successfully all in R. Xu Fei
and I well, when we were
looking at this use case,
we realized that we
have access to this data
already in the form of
the database and the pins
that the R ETL
process is updating.
So we decided to,
in order to address
the needs of a team which
uses a similar workflow, where
part of the workflow
is in one language
and part of the workflow
is in another language,
we decided that we'll
build the model,
build the dashboards in Python
all within our RStudio products.
So let's take a look at
the application itself.
So this is developed
in Shiny for Python
as you heard yesterday
deployed on RStudio
Connect which we will get
into the second you see
a map of the DC
area and there are
circles with numbers in them.
These represented this
cluster of bike stations.
If you click into
it, it zooms in
and eventually we'll see
blue circles that represents
the stations themselves.
The bigger the circle, the
more bikes that are available.
And if you click on
one of the circles,
it's going to give you
the predictive graph
of the number of bikes
available in the next 24 hours.
So you heard of RStudio Team and
RStudio professional products
and what are they
and why do we need them,
and how does Python fit in here?
RStudio Team is
actually an umbrella term
for three professional products,
namely Workbench, Connect
and Package Manager.
As Python data
scientists, we need
a place to start writing
our project and code
and we need an
environment to code.
And so Workbench offers
a centralized, server
based environment
that allows you
to code in your favorite
data science IDEs,
so Jupyter and VS Code.
As your project matures,
you may want to start
sharing your content
and deploy to somewhere.
And that's where
your RStudio Connect comes in,
it's designed
exactly for that.
And it allows you to
deploy a very wide variety
of data, data science
assets, especially
the interoperable ones
such as pins, APIs
and reports like Quarto
and Jupyter Notebooks
and interactive dashboards
like Plotly Dash, Streamlit,
and of course, our favorite and
the latest Shiny for Python.
And if you want to
install packages
into a centralized location
and that's not directly
from PyPi, you can use
Package Manager for that.
So what are what are
we going to show you
in the next few
minutes is that we're
going to show you a workflow
from developing the model using
existing interoperable data
objects in the Workbench.
And we deploy that to connect
and come back and visit
the application itself.
We'll make a change
and we'll update it
live to the Connect deployment.
So let's see the demo.
As Xu Fei mentioned, we're
going to start with we already
have access to
the data, so we're
going to start with the
model building process.
So in order for me
to start working,
I need access to the IDE.
So I go to our demo
Workbench and as Xu Fei said,
it supports multiple IDEs.
A controversial opinion,
I like to start my
work in notebooks,
especially when I'm doing model
building and data exploration.
So I'm going to choose
the IDE Jupyter Lab here
and then I'm going to launch
a Jupyter Lab session.
I've already launched
it here, and this
is the notebook I'm using to
train the model and deploy it.
And as you can see,
I might have to zoom
in a bit, a little bit more.
Cool So I'm beginning
with all the basics,
starting with importing all
the packages that I need
in my work, setting
about my environment,
providing API keys and
database passwords.
I've also built some
functions for repeatable code
that I'm going to
use later, and this
is where I start
making a connection
to the database, which has all
the data about the bike stored.
So this database is being
updated by the R ETL process,
so I don't need to do the
data cleaning and exploration.
I can directly import this data
as a data frame in my Python
environment.
And I can create a testing
and training data set
and start building my model.
So for this work, we chose
the random forest model,
but like another
iteration of this work
can be building
different kinds of models
and comparing the performances.
But let's take the random
forest for this one.
And now I build the model.
I need to test it.
So I create my testing set
and I compare the results
with the actual data.
What I have done here
so far is what we do every
day as data scientists.
Right? and maybe you all
can do it better than I did.
But the next challenge for
me is to move this model out
of my notebook
into a place where
other applications can consume
the predictions it's making.
And this is where I'm going to
use a combination of vetiver
and RStudio Connect.
So as Julia introduced vetiver
in her keynote yesterday
and also Isabel gave a
great talk about using vetiver
in ML Ops operations, I'm going
to skip explaining vetiver,
but I'm going to show you
how I use it in my work.
So in order to start working, I
will convert the random forest
model that I just built
into a vetiver model
so that vetiver can
interact with it.
And once I've converted that,
I will pin this vetiver model
onto an RSConnect board.
Yes, this is the
same pins package
that is available in R, but now
it's also available in Python
and it's used in vetiver
for model versioning.
And once I've pinned the
model onto RStudio Connect,
I will deploy it as a Fast API
endpoint onto Connect itself.
And I'm using the
in-built function
from vetiver called
vetiver_deploy_rsconnect.
So what this
function is doing is
I'm passing the name of the
pin directly to the function
and it's converting this
function into a Fast API,
converting this
model into a Fast API
and directly deploying it on
my RStudio Connect instance.
So you can see right? Like
from a few lines of code
under 10 lines of code,
I was able to move
this model from my notebook into
Connect using vetiver.
So I've done the deployment
to save us time here.
Let's see what the
deployment looks like.
So this is my deployed
model as a Fast API
on to RStudio Connect.
So I get access to these docs
that the Fast API provides.
I can see the API URL, I can
see what kind of features
it's taking.
I can make a sample prediction,
I can play with it too.
As this is API is running
on RStudio Connect,
I get access to
all these features,
which is what Connect
provides so I can decide who
I want to share this API with.
I can change the runtime
credentials for this API.
I can manage it here.
What I've done so
far is run my run
the model once on the current
state of the database.
But the R process is updating
this database every day
because the number of bikes
are changing every day.
So that data is also
getting refreshed.
So my next task is to update
my model with the latest data.
So that it's always available
with the right data,
the current data.
So for this work, I'm also
again using RStudio Connect.
RStudio Connect
provides you the ability
to deploy a Jupyter
Notebook and schedule it.
So I'm going to deploy
this Jupyter Notebook using
the Git-based deployment
in RStudio Connect.
This is one of the many types
of deployment available.
I'm going to use Git
based to make sure
that my code on my Git repo
is consistent with what
is available on RStudio
Connect. Again to save us time,
this is a short talk, I've
already deployed this notebook
on RStudio Connect.
And this is what it looks like.
The same notebook
that I had in my IDE
and I'm going to use the
schedule feature of RStudio
Connect, create a schedule to
run this notebook every time
the data is updated.
All right.
So far, we have
seen the process
of developing the
model in Workbench
and deploy to Connect,
and let it run
as a notebook on
a regular basis.
For this part, I'm going
to show you the app itself,
and we're going to make
a change in the app
and we'll live deploy to
our server, Connect server
and we'll see how it works.
So right now, just take a
look back at the app again.
This time I wanted
you to pay attention
to the color of these circles.
It looks like a blue-ish.
Just keep that in mind.
It's going to be
relevant in a second.
I'm going to show
you something here.
So we made this application
in Shiny for Python.
It's very, very exciting
to use this package.
And I learned a lot from this.
And in fact, I actually
find the documentation
and this online
examples, it's kind
of magical WASM
tutorials, really helpful.
And if you want to
learn more about it,
Winston has the talk
right coming up right next
after our talk.
So definitely stay for that.
What I wanted to
highlight here in the code
is the interoperability
that really saved us
a lot of time, as Gagan mentioned,
that we can actually use pins
the pins packaging.
So this is the Python pins.
And I'm reading a pin that's
generated by my colleagues, Sam
and Alex.
This pin was generated
from a Quarto document
that's running on the schedule.
So basically it takes
the bike station information,
process it and stores in the
pin and and updates it every day.
So I don't have to do anything.
I just have to read
it into a data frame
and use the data frame
in my application.
So it's really handy for me.
And at the same time, I also
use the vetiver endpoint
to use Gagan's API to
predict the number of bikes.
So here in the next, I'm
going to show you the update.
Now I mentioned
the color, right?
I don't really like
the dark blue color.
It looks a little
depressing to me going.
Gagan do you have
any suggestions?
Yeah, let's make it orange.
One of our new colors.
OK, so let's change
it to orange.
All right, change made.
And so what I would do in
this case, we're going to.
Deploy to the Connect server and
I'm going to run it right now
and we'll explain in a
second what it means.
So you probably
cannot see everything,
so I'm just going to explain
in general concepts. First,
when you deploy to Connect,
as Connect supports
a very large list of content
that's that you can host
and you can deploy.
The content we chose is
Shiny because we support it.
But if you want to use
Streamlit or Plotly Dash,
these interactive contents
dashboards, totally
supported as well.
On the other hand, the
Connect server, you need
to specify where it is.
So I'm going to just go to
the app, refresh a little bit.
And you also have
to pay attention
to the virtual environment
because in Python
it is very important.
You want to isolate
your environment.
So that you have sufficient
package isolation.
And so what Connect does
at this point is that when
you send the command and it
uses the rsconnect package,
right? This
rsconnect-python package allows
you to programmatically
deploy the content
to Connect using a command line.
And it wraps your
content into a bundle
first and uploads
the bundle that
includes the application itself,
the requirements dot text.
So that Connect first will
look for the compatible Python
version on the
server itself and it
will use the compatible version
of Python to run the app
and uses the
requirements dot text
to rebuild the environment.
So each deployment is sandboxed.
It is robust against
future deployments.
It does not impact
previous deployments.
It guarantees to
run all the time.
So that is really handy for us.
And, and at the end,
you can see that there
is success with the
little green links here.
And let's go back
to the app again.
Let's zoom in a little bit more,
see the orange circles, right?
And if you click on
one of them and you are
going to see the predictions.
So, all right, we made a change
and it's live on Connect again.
So let's take a look
back at what we just did.
We started off with R-based
ETL jobs that's been running
and it's been processing
on Connect
and we started building Python
models using vetiver, pins,
all the good things
in Workbench, and we
deployedt to Connect so
that it keeps running.
And we also used
the content that's
deployed to Connect API
in our Shiny Python dashboard
to serve our purpose,
to actually inform us
with the future deployments
of future predictions
of the number of bikes.
Now, what does it mean to you?
If you're already
working in Python
and you have access
to the RStudio Team
professional products,
well can just
start using your favorite
Python tools today.
There's really no need to wait.
And if you work with
Python colleagues,
we just showed you a
very simple example,
but I hope they can serve as a
little starting point for you
to collaborate and extend
the capabilities across teams
between Python and R
teams so that all
within the RStudio
Team what we can offer.
And we definitely hope you
can take it to the next level
than what we did.
So what's next for
you after this, doc?
We introduced a lot
about our pro products today,
so Xu Fei and I and most
of our customer-facing team
is at the lounge right
outside the room.
So come see us, have a chat.
All the assets that we built
and all the code behind
it, we have made it public.
And if you have access
to our pro products
and want to start
using Python, there's
documentation on enabling
Jupyter and VS Code
sessions in there.
And as Xu Fei was
saying, you can deploy
multiple different
contents on Connect.
So the deployment guide
is also available.
We also use some
really exciting Python
packages that we introduce
as part of the conference.
So there's great documentation
available for that.
And that's our talk.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.